Unreal has a number of powerful tools, but probably the most important one to emphasize
for Sequencer is its camera tools.
Unreal leverages two primary types of cameras.
The Cinemate Camera Actor is the camera of choice for creating sequences and shots for
cinematic creation or film production.
It's designed to emulate a physical camera while maintaining features that allow control
over the film back, lens, focus, tracking, and post-processes.
The Game Camera Actor is the preferred camera for games because of its simplicity.
Intended for use as the player's view camera, additional cinematic controls are unnecessary.
To place a cinematic camera into your level, go to the Place Actors tab, choose Cine, and
then drag a Cinemate Camera Actor into your scene.
This will give you a possessible camera.
If you're wanting a spawnable camera, you can choose to use the Create Camera button
in Sequencer's UI.
Once available, you'll be able to see the range of cinematic settings in the Details
Editor.
Camera binding information can be found by looking in the priority information within
the Camera Cuts track or by using the Selection Details window.
The primary settings of the Cinemate Camera that are important to note are, film back
presets with options to manually alter the sensor size, lens settings like focal length,
f-stop, squeeze factor, and diaphragm blade count.
These settings are available for setting manual focus distance, a debug focus plane,
and focus offsets, and tracking settings allow for look-at tracking.
Finally, post-process settings allow the camera to have specialized effects like color grading,
film grain, and other more advanced render settings.
You might have noticed that whenever a Cinemate Camera Actor is added to Sequencer for the
first time, a Camera Cuts track is automatically generated.
The Camera Cuts track is responsible for binding specific cameras to edited cuts within Sequencer's
timeline.
Remember that the Selection Details panel or the property settings within the Camera Cuts
track can give you access to the binding ID or special blueprint conditions.
There are also different variations of camera components.
The Scene Capture Component 2D captures a live snapshot of the scene from any camera
and feeds it to a render target texture.
Look if it like a broadcast camera that beams an image to a receiving television set.
The Cinic Capture Component 2D is just like the Scene Capture Component 2D, but includes
all the powers and capabilities of a Cinematic Camera, things like post-processing, OcIO,
and lens distortion are supported.
The VCam Actor is used to transmit camera motion and control settings remotely through
the LiveLink plugin, and lens components are used to create calibrated lens files to match
physical camera conditions and apply lens distortions.
Welcome to my camera demo.
In order to access the Cinematic Camera, go to the Place Actors tab and choose Cine.
Here you'll find several tools associated with the Cinematic Camera, including the Cinematic
Camera itself.
If you click and drag a Cinematic Camera into your level, you'll create a possessible
camera that you'll have to separately add into Sequencer.
If you only need a spawnable camera, then click on the Create Camera button in the Sequencer
UI, and a camera will be added along with its Camera Cuts track.
I've created a quick little demo to showcase some of the most used camera settings.
You won't have this level in your file, but it's quite easy to set up.
Just a couple of cubes and a few keyframes, and you're done.
Now I've split the viewport into two panes.
The pane on the left is what is known as the Cinematic Viewport.
This viewport shows you exactly what the camera or camera cuts track is seeing.
It also provides you with some extra functionality, like some overlays, some masking features,
and transport controls to help you with your cinematic choices.
The view on the right, this is the default viewport.
This viewport I've set up as my God Camera, and it allows me to observe the entire scene
objectively, so it can be very helpful when planning out my action.
And if we select on a camera, over here on the right, we'll find the Details panel where
all the settings are located.
We'll take a look at the focus settings, the look at settings, the focal length, and current
aperture fields.
Okay, let's get started.
All digital cameras use an electronic sensor to capture images, and those sensors are measured
in millimeters.
Unreal provides you with a range of different camera options in this drop-down menu.
By selecting a different setting, you're altering the dimensions of the camera sensor.
This will result in a different aspect ratio.
If your camera isn't listed, you can simply insert your camera sensor measurements into
custom height and width fields.
If you're attempting to replicate a traditional film camera's aperture dimensions, remember,
they're measured in inches, so you'll have to convert to metric.
For lensing options, Unreal does have a small selection of primes and a universal zoom setting.
The custom setting allows you to set your min, max, focal length, and f-stops.
A squeeze factor and diaphragm blade count settings are also available if you're trying
to emulate anamorphic lenses or attempting to modify the bokeh.
Also, the current focal length field allows you to change your focal length and the resulting
horizontal field of view accordingly.
Unreal supports four different focus modes.
Use Do Not Override to prevent altering post-process volume settings, Manual Focus for setting a
specific focus distance, Tracking for tracking actors, and Disable to turn everything focus
related off.
If you happen to be looking for that fancy depth of field effect, a lot depends on which
film back you're using, the focal length, and the value of your current aperture setting.
However, in general, the lower the aperture number, the shallower the depth of field.
The higher the number, the deeper the depth of field.
If you're focusing on something close to the camera, the aperture will dictate how in-focus
things will be in the distance.
I'd recommend using values aligned with the classic F-stop numbers, F1 through F22, F1
for a blurry background, and F22 for the sharpest.
Regarding focus, we can manually set our focus distance by typing in a distance measurement
or by using the eyedropper tool.
You can select actors in your level and the focus distance will be changed.
Be sure to do this in the window that is actively piloting your camera, otherwise this functionality
will not work.
If you turn on the Debug Focus Plane option, you can see exactly where the focal plane
will be placed.
Next, focus tracking can be used to track an object in order to set the focus.
Simply activate Focus Tracking and select your focusing object to track.
In my animated example, the cube remains in focus as it travels up and down the road.
Look at tracking is also available.
Select your desired actor to track and this function will lock on to its pivot point.
If necessary, you can supply offset values to move the look at point if required.
The Cine Camera is a very robust tool and there are so many settings that we could explore,
but for now, you have some of the most important basics to start creating some interesting shots.
Let's move on to our next module.